china es el país más contaminante del
mundo y también el mayor consumidor de
energía seguro que esto nos pilla por
sorpresa verdad
pues precisamente por este motivo el
gigante asiático juega un papel clave
para que se puedan cumplir los objetivos
climáticos del acuerdo de parís un
acuerdo que busca limitar a un máximo de
dos grados el calentamiento global
[Música]
y en toda esta operación reducir el uso
del carbón para producir energía es algo
fundamental de hecho siguiendo el
acuerdo de parís este tipo de combustión
debería eliminarse para el 2050 en todo
el mundo
[Música]
al día de hoy china emite el 30 por
ciento de todas las emisiones de dióxido
de carbono sin embargo al mismo tiempo
el gigante acético supone el 20 por
ciento de todas las manufacturas
globales es decir chinas sigue siendo
muy ineficiente a la hora de gestionar
la contaminación y esto es algo que
tiene mucho que ver con su alta
dependencia del carbón como combustible
para sus centrales eléctricas
[Música]
el carbón es un medio muy barato para
producir energía y china por ser
reservas de carbón a punta pala y si a
cero mucho se hizo creer al mundo que
estas centrales llamémosles sucias iban
a tener los días o los años contados y
eso ya no está tan claro
no
queridos amigos de visual político
sigilosamente china parece haber dado
marcha atrás al compromiso que el propio
xi jinping lanzó hace poco tiempo o al
menos lo ha frenado en seco
en este vídeo os vamos a contar cómo y
por qué china ha decidido mirar de
perfil al problema de la contaminación
que supone el carbón y también qué
podemos esperar atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
fijaos en estas dos noticias tienen una
diferencia de tan solo tres años sin
advierta trump contra el abandono del
acuerdo sobre el cambio climático años
después de congelar nuevos proyectos
china vuelve a construir plantas de
carbón sorprendidos pues no deberíais xi
jinping eso de predicar con el ejemplo
no lo lleva del todo bien es cierto que
se han producido avances pero hoy por
hoy el divorcio entre china y el carbón
es algo que genera mucho espero que
muchos interrogantes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
china sigue siendo un país en vías de
desarrollo y por tanto su demanda de
energía no solo empujada por la
industria sino ahora también por su
pujante clase media crece crece y crece
sin parar literalmente china devora
energía es decir el gran gigante
asiático aún está muy lejos de llegar al
punto en el que estamos por ejemplo en
europa donde con energías más limpias y
mejoras de eficiencia pues podemos
aspirar a mantener a raya tanto el
consumo energético como las emisiones de
co2 todo lo contrario de lo que ocurre
en china
[Música]
de hecho a pesar de las promesas y los
diferentes planes del gobierno chino
este país no solo no está reduciendo su
producción eléctrica con carbón sino que
incluso la está incrementando y con ella
las emisiones las emisiones chinas
ligadas al carbón crecen cada año
queréis más detalles
china y el carbón divorcio imposible
amigos en la relación de china con el
carbón hay un hecho determinante hoy por
hoy china simplemente no puede y tampoco
quiere dejar de producir energía a
partir del carbón no puede da igual lo
que te hayan contado no va a ocurrir
os lo contábamos al principio el gran
gigante asiático ha vuelto a permitir la
construcción de centrales
termoeléctricas de carbón en al menos 11
provincias y no creáis que estamos
hablando de una ni dos ni tres centrales
nuevas ni siquiera de diez
hablamos de desbloquear al menos dos
docenas de nuevas centrales algunas de
ellas enormes que incrementarán la
producción energética china de carbón en
150 gigavatios para que os hagáis una
idea es prácticamente la producción
eléctrica con carbón de toda la unión
europea
[Música]
y no sólo eso para abastecer todas esas
nuevas centrales está previsto que los
próximos años se abran 40 nuevas minas
de carbón es decir se crearán miles y
miles de puestos de trabajo vinculados a
esta industria que no tiene futuro en
china'
y hablamos tan solo de un par de años
ahora bien un momento significa esto que
china le ha dado definitivamente la
espalda a su compromiso de reducir la
contaminación que lo único que podemos
esperar es a que china contamine más más
y más pues no no exactamente no del todo
al menos siempre y cuando hablemos en
términos relativos claro
fijaos
[Música]
desde el 2012 el porcentaje del mix
energético producido por carbón ha caído
del 68 5% al 59% en 2018 en 6 años china
ha pasado de producir con carbón más de
dos tercios de toda su energía a poco
más de la mitad sigue siendo un
porcentaje enorme pero la reducción es
considerable y ese es precisamente el
dato que utiliza el gobierno para sacar
pecho
pero claro que china ya ha reducido su
dependencia del carbón en 10 puntos pues
no parece una cifra como para echar las
campanas al vuelo' sobre todo si tenemos
en cuenta que realmente importan los
datos relativos cuando hablamos de
contaminación que importa la
distribución del mix energético si eso
significa que las emisiones derivados
del carbón continúan aumentando año tras
año pensando un momento imaginad por
ejemplo que la energía total producida
por china en un año es 1000 y unos años
más tarde pasa a ser digamos de 1500
unidades de energía pues bien supongamos
que primero se producían 700 de esas mil
unidades con carbón y unos años después
se producen con carbón 900 de las mil
quinientas técnicamente si se habrían
reducido el peso del carbón en la
producción total energética pero la
realidad es que la producción de energía
con carbón habría aumentado en 200
unidades y es que es cuando hablamos de
contaminación emisiones y medioambiente
de lo que importan son las cifras
absolutas y amigos eso es precisamente
lo que estaba ocurriendo en china
y
como podéis ver en lo que llevamos de
milenio china multiplicado por cinco la
producción de electricidad con carbón
mientras que en el mismo periodo de eeuu
y la unión europea la han reducido
sensiblemente ahora bien un momento
antes de dictar sentencia
si os digo que china además de ser el
líder mundial en energía sucia también
es el líder mundial en energía limpia
como os quedáis
pues ido digiriendo porque de hecho es
exactamente así en cifras absolutas
china produce más energía con fuentes
limpias con fuentes renovables que
ningún otro país del planeta
[Música]
728 gigavatios instalados en 2018
producidos con energías renovables un
12% más que en 2017 pero entonces cómo
es esto posible por qué demonios siguen
construyendo centrales de carbón en
lugar de ponerle el punto y final a esta
tecnología definitivamente pues amigos
lo cierto es que sobre esta cuestión hay
todo un conflicto interno veréis china
literalmente flota en carbón su subsuelo
está repleto de este mineral
hay regiones que sin el carbón de la
noche a la mañana volverían a la pobreza
absoluta hablamos de decenas de miles de
trabajadores cientos de miles de
trabajadores que comen de este sector
mineros trabajadores de las centrales
transportistas etcétera
el problema por tanto está en lo que
supondría para china eliminar el mercado
interno del carbón hoy por hoy un sector
esencial para poder mantener una
producción de bajo coste capaz de
competir en los mercados internacionales
y es aquí donde nos surge una gran
cuestión la pregunta clave será capaz
china de cumplir los plazos marcados por
la comunidad internacional para combatir
las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero realmente logra sustituir su
dependencia del carbón atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el paradigma chino de la ambición a la
realidad amigos el caso de china es un
poco más complicado de lo que parece
como habéis visto en este país eso de
dejar de construir centrales
contaminantes y pasar a depender de las
renovables después no es algo tan
sencillo lo consiguen por un lado pero
por otro empeoran la situación y es que
el problema no es nuevo viene de lejos
en la década de 1980 como todos sabéis
china vivió una explosión industrial y
económica brutal evidentemente todo eso
se había acompañado de una demanda de
energía también enorme y poder
satisfacer una demanda tan alta y con
tanto crecimiento interanual es muy
complicado
respetables de producción de energía
tardan tiempo en construirse y en entrar
en servicios sin embargo la energía se
necesitaba ya la demanda de instantánea
no se podía esperar ni meses ni años
hasta que las centrales estuvieran
listas
precisamente por eso el gobierno chino
promovió leyes que permitieran a las
empresas y a los gobiernos regionales
adelantarse a la demanda y construir así
muchas más centrales de carbón de las
necesarias en ese momento porque bueno
al fin y al cabo con esa tendencia de
demanda energética creciente se irían a
necesitar más pronto que tarde no os
parece pues bien hace relativamente poco
tiempo en el año 2014 el gobierno
central permitió a sus provincias
aprobar y construir centrales eléctricas
es decir descentralizó la toma de
decisiones y esto digamos que no fue una
idea demasiado buena no al menos si
hablamos de sustituir al carbón
[Música]
veréis los gobernantes de las provincias
chinas suelen ser personas que buscan
ascender a la esfera política nacional y
hacer carrera en el partido para llegar
a los altos cargos en el gobierno
central pero para eso tienen que
demostrar unas aptitudes una capacidad
de gestión destacable tienen que hacer
que su provincia se desarrolle se
enriquezca sea como sea por eso los
gobiernos provinciales hacen todo lo
posible y lo imposible para potenciar la
industrialización de su región
industrialización que como no va
acompañada de mucha mucha energía y por
lo tanto como veis con carbón
como veis todo parece un buen wind
siempre claro hasta que nos olvidemos
del medio ambiente y en el caso de que
los chinos estén dispuestos a salir con
la calle con una mascarilla conectada
una bombona de oxígeno porque amigos
podéis creerme cuando digo que la
polución en las ciudades chinas es un
problema de verdad y claro ante
semejante berenjenal imaginaos la imagen
internacional que daba china con este
percal en plena psicosis climática el
gobierno central se dio cuenta del error
y revirtió como os contábamos al
principio del vídeo la construcción de
un montón de nuevas centrales en 2016
paralización que ahora se ha paralizado
valga la redundancia vaya y es que en
gran medida esto se ha hecho para tratar
de estimular así una economía que los
últimos años se ha ido desacelerando
y es que en china cada vez que el
crecimiento se desacelera lo que hace el
gobierno es gastar miles y miles de
millones en todo tipo de proyectos y ahí
es donde entra precisamente la enorme
inversión en grandes centrales de carbón
y también en renovables literalmente en
montañas y montañas recubiertas de
paneles solares coronadas con
aerogeneradores y en sus ríos represas
para la producción hidroeléctrica sabéis
la salvajada de dinero que está costando
todo esto pues agarrados a la silla de
los casi 300.000 millones de dólares que
se invirtieron en energías renovables en
todo el mundo en el año 2018 tan solo
china representó más del 30 por ciento
invirtió más de 90 mil millones de
dólares y esto es lo que explica que en
sí no nos encontremos con este tipo de
paisajes 100% artificial pero también
100% sostenible y gracias a estos
paisajes tan disruptivos es por lo que
este país ha conseguido por ejemplo
estas buenas cifras en 2019 la capacidad
de la energía renovable en china aumenta
un 95 % interanual en junio así que no
si pensabais que no era posible ser
sucio y limpia mismo tiempo os
equivocáis hablamos amigos de un mix
eléctrico que si fuera una persona
tendría algo así como un claro trastorno
de bipolaridad pero volvamos a la gran
pregunta
poder a china superar su adicción al
carbón
[Música]
la demanda de energía en china crece tan
rápido que a pesar de la enorme
inversión acometida por el gobierno
central las renovables no es que no
puedan ya sustituir a otros tipos de
energía más contaminantes sino que
difícilmente pueden cubrir todo el
crecimiento de la demanda y es
precisamente ahí donde nos encontramos
con la otra gran apuesta del gobierno
chino la energía nuclear fijaos
actualmente china cuenta con 46
reactores operativos y otros 11 en
construcción
pero eso es tan sólo el comienzo
recientemente la corporación tecnológica
estatal de energía nuclear ha anunciado
que el país construirá al menos otros 60
reactores nucleares durante la próxima
década
de momento 43 ya están planificados
aprobados y cuentan con la financiación
necesaria para llevar a cabo su
construcción y eso no es todo además se
han propuesto formalmente otros 136
proyectos para su estudio al fin y al
cabo hablamos de un país donde la
energía nuclear no es ni mucho menos un
tema tabú de hecho en china podemos
encontrar iniciativas tan curiosas como
la del chain general nuclear power group
que ha llegado a invitar a parejas a
celebrar su boda ni más ni menos que en
la central nuclear de daya bay en
shenzhen eso sí a cambio de publicar sus
fotos en la red
amigos chinas está apostando fuerte por
la energía nuclear para complementar a
las renovables y tener una cosa presente
hoy por hoy esa vía parece la única
posible para que el gigante asiático
reduzca su adicción al carbón
en fin amigos llegados a este punto
turno para ti qué piensas puede china
abandonar efectivamente el carbón dejar
de construir centrales y empezar a
desmantelar las mientras siga creciendo
su industria llegará a ser china vista
algún día como ejemplo de energías
limpias en lugar de como un lugar
humeante y ambientalmente hostil qué
pensáis de que el gobierno de xi jinping
haya reactivado la construcción de
nuevas centrales de carbón lo que supone
una marcha atrás en los compromisos que
china ha adquirido en virtud del acuerdo
del país
dejadnos vuestras opiniones aquí abajo
en los comentarios que ya sabéis que nos
encanta leeros siempre tratamos de leer
todos los comentarios y si este vídeo ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like y por supuesto suscribiros avisor
polític si aún no lo habéis hecho una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]